Welcome back everyone this will be my full star
wars book of boba fett episode 3 video there's
a whole bunch of easter eggs in a bunch of big
celebrity cameos there were so many cameos in this
episode so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes we're doing a giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just leave your favorite
moment from the episode on the video careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the episode yet i'll
just start at the beginning and we'll work our way
through scene by scene talking about easter eggs
wtf moments and all the stuff they're setting up
starting with the title of the episode chapter 3
the streets of mos espa which is just a reference
to all the different subdivisions and areas of
the city with the workers district the city center
the starport the upper sprawl because we spend
most of this episode exploring the rest of the
city in a way we have it in previous episodes
or even in the star wars movies we also meet a
bunch of the people that actually live here
they turn them into much bigger characters
and they sort of set up the idea that there are
a bunch of other crime families which we actually
seen in the trailer we'll meet them in the future
episodes because they'll become a big part of boba
pet's fight against the pyke syndicate which just
rolled in but the actual opening scene is one of
the bomar monks the spider droids from return of
the jedi it's basically this order of monks that
put their brains in jars and they try to live
in this enlightened state but when they need to
actually move around because they're just brains
in jars they actually attach the jars to these
spider bodies and they operate them kind of like
cybernetic bodies the events of the episode pick
up right after they had their run-in with jabba's
twin cousins and the wookie bounty hunter black
krrsantan the 8D8 droid also pulls this funny
harry potter reference here you see the businesses
that were under the protection of the name that
should not be spoken you can say jabba boba fett
having to tell him it's okay you can actually say
jabba's name he gives us all the backstory for
what happened after the events of return of the
jedi on tatooine basically saying that after jabba
was killed by princess leia his sail barge was
destroyed bib fortuna immediately assumed control
of jabba's empire and then divided up control of
most amongst these three crime families that we'll
meet in either next week's episode of the episode
after that probably pretty soon the trandoshans
took control of the city center which explains why
we've seen so many of them hanging out near the
mayor's office in last week's episode the aqualish
took control of the workers district which we
visit later in this episode in the klatooinians
took control of the upper sprawl in the star port
which we visit at the end of the episode when
the giant pyke star cruiser rolls in but the
idea is that bib fortuna was allowing these three
different crime families and the mayor himself
to line their pockets as long as they paid him a
portion of the tribute that jabba used to extract
from the region but you all probably figured out
that all these other groups had been skimming off
so many profits bib fortuna was probably only
getting like a small fraction of the money that
jabba used to get and they kind of implied in
last week's episode that he was terrible at being
a crime boss so as they explained with a swoop
gang later in the water merchant the area's kind
of fallen into complete chaos under bib fortuna
so it's just another problem for boba fett to
fix if he wants to rule over tatooine they really
pile on boba fett in this episode they really do
not want to make it easy for him when fennec shand
says that she's not totally convinced that it was
jabba's family the twins that sent the assassins
to try and kill them during episode two they wind
up paying that off at the end of the episode when
they reveal the mayor's connection to the pykes
saying that he basically sold tatooine to the
pykes they're basically trying to tell you that
the pykes are the ones that sent the assassins
there are a lot of theories that there's also
other big players that will see cameo in later
episodes like emilia clarke's Qi'ra kodoe's cameo
because she might have taken over crimson dawn
when obi-wan kenobi finally killed darth maul for
the last time for like the third time there are
just a lot of other crime syndicates out there
the pyke syndicate was really big during star wars
the clone wars so i think they're trying to set
them up as big villains right now but there are
other crime syndicates that we could see during
the series but we get our next big celebrity guest
cameo at the top of the episode it's steven root
who you probably remember from billions of
movies and television shows you remember him
from somewhere recently he's playing lortha peal
a water merchant in the workers district water
being a precious resource on tatooine because
it's a desert planet is basically the other side
of what owen and beru lars were doing they were
moisture farmers so they sell their supply in bulk
to people like this guy and then he turns around
and sells it in the city on the secondary market
they use his plea to sort of set up this whole
idea that boba fett has to deal with all this
chaos in the city like you're gonna have to fix
the city if you're going to rule tatooine they're
all these little street level problems they asked
to solve and even though we don't get into in this
episode they just set up the idea that there
are the other crime families that rule over
these specific areas of the city he'll also have
to deal with on top of that but as you can kind
of see they're trying to set up this parallel with
steven root's merchant character in the swoop gang
for what happened with the tusken raiders in the
flashbacks the whole fake out twist with people
that you think used to be villains but were just
portrayed in really bad light like no no no the
tusken raiders aren't bad people they're just
a couple tribes who survive by killing people
same thing with the swoop gang they seem like
they're bad based on what the water merchant
tells them but turns out he's the real dirtbag
they make more references to boba fett's visions
and the flashbacks that we just saw in episode 2
when he was tripping balls when the water merchant
says tatooine used to be covered in water boba
fett also mentions growing up on the water planet
kamino they do this funny thing too where he
launches into this really fascinating story about
what actually happened to all of tatooine's water
but boba fett stops him short because i think
they're saving that for a later episode at the end
of boba fett's visions during episode two you see
water bursting out of the ground as he bursts out
of the sarlacc pit and i think they're trying to
draw this parallel between what was happening
with the fremen's hidden underground aquifers
in the oceans worth of water that they had and
eventually water covering the planet again like
eventually this might turn into a bigger thing
with boba fett trying to make water more available
for everyone early theory they'll probably find
underground aquifers with tons of water there's
a really subtle darth vader reference that he also
makes when he talks about the street gang saying
half man half machine the darth vader line is he's
more machine than man now he's more machine now
than man twisted and evil then just like we see
the other parts of the city during the episode
boba fett takes us to the actual workers district
there's a couple of jaws the jaws with the yellow
eyes are the ones that are native to tatooine
off-world jawas will sometimes have red eyes there
are a couple of aqualish behind them here as they
walk past remember it's the aqualish crime family
that controls this area of the city then we meet
the swoop gang with all their bikes so swoops are
basically just more dangerous bigger versions of
regular speeder bikes this is sophie thatcher you
might remember her from yellowjacket she's playing
a character named drash she's got a cybernetic arm
this character with a cybernetic eye implant is
called skad we see him at the end of the episode
monitoring the star port for boba fett when
the pyke show up but proving that he is trying
to be a good ruler boba fett does try to solve
their problems in a very boba fett kind of way
like there's a compromise nobody is really happy
but he does wind up giving the swoop by gangs
a job like you'll come work for me the merchant
seems like he's super pissed and he might go run
to the aqualish and complain about boba fett just
causing more problems for him in future episodes
it seems like this is not the end of this matter
but back in the tank boba fett flashes back again
to kamino watching his father jango fett take
off for mission in the slave one and it's meant
to be a longer version of the exact same vision
that he had when he was tripping balls becoming
a part of the tuskenn raider tribe in episode two
which also leads him to flashback to right after
the events of that episode rolling out of camp
riding on abantha to go get their first payment
of tribute that they arranged with the pykes and
it seems like just based on what's happening in
mos eisley here when he rolls in this is meant
to be happening right before the events of the
mandalorian series because as he's rolling into
town he rides past all the stormtrooper helmets
and they're being put on the pykes but we get our
next big celebrity guest cameo the pyke captain
is being played by phil lamar who you'll probably
remember from a billion other tv shows he's been
on he's been a bunch of different characters
during the star wars clone wars episodes
he also played bale organa during star wars rebels
he basically sets up the whole conflict with the
red nicto gang from episode 2 and episode 1. he
actually gives their gang a name calling them the
kinton striders telling him in so many words that
we'd be happy to give you and the tuskens all this
protection money as long as you get rid of this
other gang for us but it's meant to be the same
gang who boba fett stole the speeder bikes from
atashi's station in anchor head during episode two
the one with the big cameo scene from a new hope
luke skywalker's childhood friends cammy and fixer
and when he returns to his tribe to find them all
killed by that red necto gang it's just meant to
be his version of the owen baru large scene like
you're meant to have this ptsd luke skywalker
flashback to a new hope like oh my god they're
dead so this is meant to be part of his motivation
for wanting to take control of tatooine and
present day to get justice for tuskens in general
not just killing the red nectos to get revenge
we'll probably see that in the next episode
but this explains why we haven't seen his group
of tuskens in the present day timeline because
they were all killed him burning the bodies here
i think is meant to be happening right before the
events the mandalorian season one when we saw the
tatooine episode where fennec shand got killed
like i think right after this he heads back to
tatooine and probably finds her body and then
helps rescue her they did confirm that that was
meant to be boba fett at the end of that episode
just walking up to her body then we get that great
rude awakening scene from black krrsantan and
the funny thing here is that they actually worked
together during the events of the original trilogy
when his wookiee character debuted for the first
time in the darth vader comics he also showed up
during the dr aphra comics too so that's why you
probably seen a lot of people wondering if dr
aphra is going to show up during these live-action
star wars series really soon but the funnier thing
is that they actually know each other like they
actually went on a mission together so it's not
so much a fight it's really more boba fett trying
to slow him down because he's so huge and karma
comes back around the swoop by gang rescues him
they're kind of trying to establish that idea in
the series the whole idea of karma like boba fett
is actually trying to do something positive help
the tuskens trying to help all these other people
he's not quite so cold as he came off during the
original trilogy so eventually all these other
people will wind up helping him we see another
example of that later in the episode when the
twins show up with the baby rancor in tow but
this whole idea of karma paying him back for
all the good will that he's offering these other
people that work under him he even offers his back
to tank to the gomorian guard that black krrsantan
took down when they rolled down the staircase who
fennec shand then trapdoor sending into the rank
corporate second time that we've gotten a rancor
pit scene setting up obviously the big rancor
reveal when jabba's twin cousins gift him with
the baby rancor it kind of reminds you of jabba's
baby rancor moochie muchi was not the rancor that
luke skywalker killed and returned the jedi either
we don't really know what happened to him and i
know a lot of you have also asked what happened
to jabba's son because he basically debuted in the
very first clone wars episodes it was basically
the clone wars movie but it was like the first
four episodes just bundled together no idea what
happened to jabba's son but because the hutt twins
say they're going back to now huda and they're
foregoing any claim to jabba's former territory on
tatooine makes me think that we probably are not
going to see jabba's son during the series like
the hutts are basically waving their hands saying
goodbye we don't want anything to do with tatooine
anymore but even though it is jabba's family
showing up with this baby rancor i don't think
this one is meant to be moochie from the bad
batch episodes i think it's meant to be a totally
new one with danny trejo no less don't worry i'll
talk about his scene in a second too because he
sets up this whole new mythology for the rancors
we see jabba's banquet hall for the first time we
keep seeing new rooms inside jabba's palace that's
part of the idea of this series it's a huge
palace with a ton of rooms but you only saw
like a small fraction of them during return of the
jedi then the twins show up claiming that the baby
rancor is restitution for what happened with them
sending black krrsantan after him in how they just
found out what happened with the mayor in the
pykes and that's why they're leaving tatooine
they also basically give him black krrsantan do
whatever you want to with them sell them back to
the gladiators for money but like i said the whole
idea karma coming back around boba fett lets him
go and gives him some friendly advice like don't
work for dirt bags because it doesn't pay i don't
know if this means that he has a life debt to boba
fett now but they do have this weird kind of dark
han solo chewbacca thing going on between the two
of them so i think because he did such a solid for
black krrsanta.n black krrsantan will come back
and help him with the pykes later in the series
like this is not the last we've seen of the giant
wookie bounty hunter i think the bigger thing
from this scene in addition to the rancor like
literally big thing metaphorically the big thing
is the idea that they're setting the pykes up is
the big villains of the series so when jabba's
twins said they were lied to by the mayor and
another syndicate had been promised this territory
they're talking about the pyke syndicate setting
up the end of the episode when they roll into mos
espa they do renounce the hutt's legacy on
tatooine saying that it's basically this
worthless rock to them they don't care about it
and war is bad for business they don't want to
start something between the hutts and the pyke
syndicate it's not that they're cowards the huds
are a very powerful syndicate it's just that
they are correct they would lose money if they
started a war wars are very expensive but we get
our danny trejo cameo next big celebrity cameo
like i said tons of celebrities in this episode
he's playing another rancor trainer i think he's
wearing a similar harness to the one worn by the
rank or trainer in return of the jedi but he's
basically like the rancor whisperer teaching boba
fett all about the ways of the rancor in the funny
connection to the tusken raiders storyline is
they're trying to do the same thing for raincourse
that they did for the tuskens in the series try to
provide a more complex picture of the culture from
their people danny trejo's character tells them
that they're kind of like dogs they're super loyal
even though most people only value them for their
fighting abilities and that they imprint on the
first person they see jabba's rancors were like
his most prized possessions so they're setting
up a similar relationship between boba fett
and his new rancor meaning in a future episode
we'll probably see boba fett unleash the rancor on
someone and when they reference dathomir dathomir
is where the rancor species comes from so when
danny trejo's character talks about the witches
riding them in the forest he's talking about the
nightsisters it's why you don't see tons of rancor
in captivity all over the galaxy because they're
really hard to capture in the wild but that whole
speech about the night sisters riding the rank
course inspires boba fett to learn to ride this
rancor so we'll probably see them pay that off
in a future episode like a full-on giant battle
with boba fett riding a rancor hopefully we'll
also see a traditional return of the jedi style
rancor pit scene where the rancor eats someone
but just imagine what george lucas could have done
with modern special effects imagine like a big
raincore scene like that there's a really funny
easter egg too when boba fett says he's ridden
beasts 10 times its size he's actually talking
about the mythosaur that he rode in his first
appearance it's a huge deep cut easter egg for
the star wars holiday special that was boba fett's
first appearance and during that he came for luke
skywalker riding a mythosaur they referenced the
mythosaurs during the mandalorian season one as
well because mando was based on boba fett and
his special rifle was inspired by the rifle that
boba fett used in the holiday special the symbol
on boba fett's arm the crest here is the skull
of a mythosaur they also use that as the crest of
this group of mandalorians that mando belongs to
during mando season 1. talk about more mandalorian
parallels and easter eggs too the scene of the
rancor imprinting on boba fett also kind of
reminds you of grogu forming his relationship
with mando for the first time so the rancor is
sort of like boba fett's version of a baby yoda
like a baby that's incredibly powerful issues
that this one is physically huge compared to grogu
then they just confirm everyone's suspicions
and theories about what's really been happening
with the mayor in the pykes fennec shand uses the
dank farrik curse word again that's the star wars
equivalent of the f-bomb they used it all the time
during the mandalorian season one in season two
when the major dormo tries to escape he almost
takes out a c-3po droid a bunch of mouse droids
that we saw during a new hope on the death star a
bunch of pit droids from phantom menace the land
speeder he's using is a little bit different from
luke skywalker's landspeeder but it does have some
similar features in the picture of jabba's palace
that they destroy is another huge easter egg this
is literally a piece of ralph mccrory's original
concept art from the movie with boba fett standing
here next to jabba behind them here you can see is
the original concept design for what bib fortuna
was supposed to look like he almost takes out
a couple biff and then boba fett finally uses
his jetpack i believe this is the first time in
the series that he's actually used his jet pack
at least in present day then as we see the pyke
syndicate roll in i can't remember if we've
actually seen this class of starship before in the
star wars universe so if you think you remember
this from either the clone wars episodes or the
rebels episodes just right below in the comments
but they end the episode with this thread of
war with the pykes trying to make you think
that they're the real villains of the series like
this is just one of many waves of pyke troops and
warships that will roll into tatooine so the
idea in next week's episode is that boba fett
will have to rally more support from the other
crime families in the area just to have a shot
at defeating the pykes and he'll need way more
than just that like it's going to take some major
resources in a bunch of ships it also won't hurt
to get a little help from that baby rancor that
they're training him to ride and black krrsantan
and coming back to help him out but if you spotted
any other big easter eggs in the episode that
i didn't talk about during the video just write
them below in the comments post all your theories
about how this is going to play out my full book
of boba fett episode 4 video will post next week
just like normal the other really big thing that's
happening this week is that dc is dropping the
peacemaker series the first three episodes are
coming out on thursday it's a thursday show so
i'll probably do a combined video for those first
three episodes and we'll see after that but it
is connected to the dc tv universe justice league
all the other recent big dc movies everyone
click here for all my star wars book of boba
fett episode videos and click here to learn about
marvel's new black panther and that avengers 5
first look thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!